an attempted terror attack in New York
City Roy Moore is on the ballot tomorrow
and President Trump is now in the
crosshairs of Democrats focused on
sexual harassment I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
I hope you had a wonderful and relaxing
weekend we certainly did in the Shapiro
household but now we're back and there's
a lot of news as always so it turns out
that the Senate Republicans can't write
a tax bill there are certain rates in
the tax bill that are above 100 percent
no I am not kidding and there was an
attempted suicide bombing in New York
plus a bunch of the old Donald Trump
accusers are back and better than ever
we'll talk about all of these things but
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at texture so in the era
of digital journalism and the era of
attention spans that lasts approximately
0.77 30 seconds somewhere in that
neighborhood what you actually want is
in-depth journalism a lot of the time
and the only folks doing that
unfortunately are some of the folks in
the magazine business well that's what
texture is for the texture app gives you
unlimited access to 200 premium
magazines
it has titles like Time the Atlantic The
New Yorker Vanity Fair and Wired if
you're watching The New Yorker coverage
of all of the sexual harassment sexual
assault allegations out of Hollywood it
was the New Yorker doing all of the
heavy lifting the Atlantic has a lot of
very in-depth articles about foreign
policy that are really fascinating and
instead of you having to pay for a
separate subscription for each one of
these magazines instead the texture app
allows you unlimited access to 200 of
them to help inform entertain inspire
you this winter and right now you can
try texture for free
well you have to do is go to texture
calm slash Ben and you can start your
free trial there if you choose to
continue and my podcast listeners watch
to get texture for just $9.99 a month
which is 30% off they're listed price
you get it less expensive than it would
normally be textured calm / ben if
you're addicted to information you're
stuck in the car you don't know what to
do well if you have your text your app
number you don't ever have to be bored
again plus you can learn all the time
texture calm / Ben this texture calm /
Ben use that free trial and then keep
using and they'll they'll give you the
$9.99 a month deal which is again 30%
off their normal price texture calm /
Ben we use it in our house I use it my
wife uses it it's fantastic product ok
so we begin today with this attempted
terror attack in New York City so here
is the latest there's a guy who
basically was intending apparently on
carrying a pipe bomb onto a bus instead
his crudely put together pipe bomb burst
in his pants so that's about as well as
these things can end hopefully he lost
his ability to copulate
you know that'd be the best that I hope
would happen to him but he did you lost
oh that's good so he so he has removed
himself from Darwin's pool so that is
excellent the according to CBS New York
a suspect carrying a crudely assembled
improvised bomb is now in custody
following a blast in the underground
walkway between Times Square and the
Port Authority bus terminal on Monday
morning the blast happened around 7:20
a.m. during morning rush hour three
other people suffered minor injuries
that are not considered life-threatening
the other three transported themselves
to area hospitals so that means they're
not too badly off they can transport
themselves they'd symptoms like ringing
ears the suspect has now been identified
as a Cayenne Ola 27 was wearing an
improvised explosive device according to
police commissioner James O'Neill I'm
shocked I thought for sure was gonna be
Bob Smith Morman out of Utah but it
turns out it was a kya hua
from Bangladesh he'd been living in
Brooklyn since 2011 he had a visa he
came in with his parents and three to
four siblings so eh a migration and
subsequently obtained a green card and
became a permanent US residents so
making sure that all of president
Trump's points about the freedom of our
immigration system are approved in one
story then this fellow decided to join
up with Isis apparently he made
statements that he was inspired by Isis
the pictures do not look good for this
guy he's a youngster 27 and again he is
a lost his um his manhood so that's
exciting
he was rushed to Bellevue Hospital with
non-life threatening injuries he
suffered burns to his hands and abdomen
the device was affixed to his body with
velcro and zip ties according to anneal
it had wires protruding from it the poor
construction caused a flash of the
explosive component but there are no
serious shrapnel injuries consistent
with a traditional pipe bomb so this guy
was gonna be a suicide bomber the first
suicide bomber in the United States
really since 9/11
federal law enforcement officials said
the device malfunction it did not fully
detonate there was the second device
found on him according to Representative
Peter King he may have been inspired by
Isis he could have been inspired by
al-qaeda that he was the very least
inspired by Islamic Islamic terrorism it
could turn out as part of a larger plot
we don't know at this point well what
the what the full story is they had shut
down the Times Square entrance to the
subway because of the terror attack but
they will be reopening it I believe
momentarily so that one ends about as
well as that one can and president Trump
has not sweeted about it yet I'm certain
that it will be
about immigration which makes perfect
sense because again this guy came in
from Bangladesh with his family and then
he was allowed to get a green card we
don't know why his parents were allowed
in the country what connections they had
if any what their story is but clearly
our vetting system is somewhat flawed
okay well all of that is happening
president Trump is going at it with the
media and rightly so so last week we
talked about this crazy story out of CNN
where CNN reported that there had been
an email that was sent to the Trump
campaign September fourth I believe it
was and the email supposedly contained a
an encrypted key to WikiLeaks documents
which would've been a shocking story
right it would have looked like actual
collusion like the WikiLeaks people were
working with the Trump campaign showing
them documents that they had stolen from
the DNC and then turned them over to the
Trump campaign for use in the campaign
shocking story except it turns out
number one it's not clear that there's a
real email number two it's not clear
anyone from the Trump administration
know but at number three and most
importantly the date of the email was
not September 4th it was September 14th
the emails were actually released
between those two dates so now it was an
encrypted key sent two emails that had
already been released publicly so the
media ran with this it was a head of CNN
it was on top of all the media outlets
it was it was it was all over the place
and then there was a story over the
weekend where David Weigel who was a
reporter over at The Washington Post he
put out a he put out a tweet that was a
picture of Trump's rally in Tuscaloosa
Florida and it was a picture of
basically an empty setting and he was
suggesting that no one showed up for
Trump turns out that was false the
entire stadium was full and so Trump
began tweeting about it here is what
President Trump tweeted about the media
he tweeted very little discussion of all
of the purposefully false and defamatory
stories put out this week by the fake
news media they're out of control
correct reporting means nothing to them
major lies written then forced to be
withdrawn after they exposed a stain on
America you want to know why nobody
believes the media because the media do
a job like this and I'm to remember who
made this point but it's a good point it
wasn't me but the point is a good one
and that is that all of the errors are
in one direction there's never an error
in journalism that actually has an
impact on Democrats right the errors in
journalism always hurt the Republicans
and so you have to think that this has
something to do with the bias in the
media right why go who is from what I
can tell a nice guy has dealt with him a
little bit but he's certainly of the
left I mean he was part
the so-called journalist on which
several years ago this would've been
like 2012 2011 in which Weigel was part
of this list of journalists who were
kind of talking about stories all of
them from a left-wing perspective Trump
at his rally talked about the fake news
and he said they are not spending any
time talking about the economy which is
also true he said things are going
really well for our economy tweeted this
out the subject the fake news spends as
little time as possible discussing stock
market hit another record high
unemployment is now at a 17-year low
companies are coming back into the u.s.
a really good news and much more to come
all of this is true right unemployment
is at a 17-year low the stock market is
in another record high and a lot of that
is due to the feeling not that President
Trump is necessarily getting huge things
done but the President Trump is not
going to threaten the economy one of the
reasons money sits on the sidelines is
uncertainty anyone in economics will
tell you uncertainty is not good for the
economy Trump does not actually create
economic uncertainty because again if
Trump is gonna do anything it's very
likely to benefit business not to harm
business the same was not true for
President Obama
so Trump is right the media spent very
little time talking about the economy
now to be fair to the media a little bit
President Trump doesn't spend a ton of
time talking about the economy either
but it is also true that the media go
out of their way to pick stories that
are not good for President Trump
Dave why go by the way came out and
apologized for having sent all of this
for have it for having sent this tweet
with the empty stadium after Trump came
out and criticized him personally and
suggested that he might be fired I
harass Wagle apologizing sure thing I
apologized I deleted the photo after
David Martok schoo told me I'd gotten it
wrong I was confused by the image of you
walking in the bottom right hand corner
it was a bad sweet on my personal
account not a story for the Washington
Post I deleted it after like 20 minutes
very fair to call me out everything I
say on Twitter is a joke except when I
say about swim 24 inches I think another
reporter in any case Michael handles
that like a man and that's the way you
should handle it when you make a mistake
so good for why go but the bottom line
is that no matter how much the media and
now attempt to walk it back the
overwhelming feeling that the media are
out to get Trump has a pretty
significant effect on how people see
politics and that means that they are
less likely to believe outlets that are
not on their side means that there even
if there are outlets on their side they
may believe that those outlets are
quote-unquote out to get politicians if
the politicians have been victimized by
the media before and
this is not good it's not good for the
media it's not good for politics it's
not good for the soul of the American
people Trump is not wrong again to
attack the media on a routine basis
media have attacked Trump on a routine
basis however the Trump's attacks on the
media are just polarizing politics even
more I wish that Trump would restrict
his attacks on media to things like the
CNN thing I think that when when Trump
attacks the media fairly I'm on his side
when he attacks it unfairly I am not on
his side but the bottom line is this is
the backdrop to the entire political
conversation we're having the reason
this is important is because now we are
involved in a in a knock-down drag-out
race in Alabama and how people are
voting in Alabama is impacted largely by
their view of the media I would suggest
that if you take - if you ask a couple
of poll questions poll question number
one how many people think that Roy Moore
is innocent and probe question number
two how many people trust the media I
would suggest that exactly the same
people who say they have no trust in the
media think Roy Moore is innocent
meaning that it's not really about Roy
Moore being innocent it's about distrust
in the media distrust of the narrative
the suggestion that Roy Moore is being
unfairly targeted and the problem is
that any resistance to Moore by anyone
is now going to be linked up by the same
people who tribute this to media they're
going to say that anyone who decides
against Moore is now part of the media
establishment part of the media Elise
and one of those people is Richard
Shelby Richard Shelby's the senior
Republican in Alabama in the Senate and
he says that he did not vote for Roy
Moore he already voted he wrote right he
voted right in you're gonna wake up on
Wednesday and one of these two men Roy
Moore or Doug Jones is going to be your
fellow senator from Alabama which one
would you rather deal with on a
professional level
well I don't have to answer that
question today I I had rather see
another Republican in there and I'm
gonna stay with that story I'm not going
to vote for the Democrat I didn't vote
for the Democrat or advocate for the
Democrat but I couldn't vote for Roy
Moore the state of Alabama deserves
better I think we we've got a lot of
great Republicans that could have won
and carried the state beautifully and
served in the Senate honorably and I
think that there's a lot of truth to
what Richard Shelby is saying here the
problem is once again people have bought
into the narrative fight and once they
bought into the narrative
they're not gonna snap out of it so
there are two polls out today on Alabama
poll number one from Fox News has the
Doug Jones up 10 points in Alabama poll
number two I believe there's a Marist
Poll suggest that Doug Jones is down 9
points in Alabama it's very difficult
for the pollsters to actually gauge what
exactly the election tomorrow is gonna
look like it could really go either way
the reason for that is you can't model
turnout in a special election number two
this issue has really polarized the
electorate and it's not clear who
exactly is going to show up to vote and
number three the media attention on the
race means that different people may
show up to vote so the pollsters are
having a very difficult time figuring
out exactly how this race is going to go
bottom line is it could go either way at
this point it's not clear that Jones is
gonna win it's not clear that Moore is
gonna lose all of that said it would not
surprise me in the slightest if more
were to win especially given again that
polarization that I'm talking about the
media every attack by the media on Roy
Moore is seen by Roy Moore supporters as
a media attack not as an element of
truth and that's exacerbated by the fact
that Barack Obama now cut a robocall ad
in favor of Doug Jones in Alabama that
is not smart Barack Obama should have
stayed out this in state that is
two-thirds Republican attacking Roy
Moore by Barack Obama is not going to be
helpful it may drive up Democrats it may
talk about Democrats a little bit but
it's gonna drive out Republicans far
more you would think President Trump is
also issuing robo calls in the more
racing he's getting very active in the
more race I think there's another reason
why by the way that is happening I think
there's another reason why Trump is
pushing more in this race and I'll tell
you why in just a second first I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
Zeile so there's very few things in life
where you can really feel wealthy
without having to be wealthy Zeile is
one of those things so Zeile is a mobile
massage one-stop shop basically so Zeile
is an app you booked a 5-star
top-quality massage at a time that works
for you
in your home so you had a rough day you
hurt yourself working out you'll hurt
yourself at work you come home and the
seal app allows you to order miss who's
basically on demand and these are all
licensed masseuses they have over 9,000
9,000 of them nationally go to Zeile
calm or on zeals iPhone or Android app
it's ze
Elcom you select from top local licensed
pre-screened massage therapists and
choose your favorite technique gender
preference time and location for your
massage they'll send again one of those
9,000 licensed masseuses with a massage
music everything you need to turn your
living room into a spa give you a five
start massage we've used it in our
family I've used seal my wife has use
deal
both my parents have used seal my
in-laws of use deal it's a very popular
thing in our family makes for a great
holiday gift to like you want to make
somebody's Christmas then just give them
a gift card or order a massage for them
it really does make a terrific gift to
help you get started our listeners right
now you get $25 off their first massage
by using the promo code Bennett at
checkout again this 25 bucks off your
first massage when you use promo code
been and check out it gets better as
well sign up for zeals massage
membership you got 20% off all your
massages plus a free massage table and
sheet set a $380 value yours free
there's no initiation fee to join the
membership just this terrific additional
savings on top of that $25 discount
you're already gonna get when you use my
promo code bed go to zeal ze Elcom or on
zeals iPhone or Android app make sure to
click add promo code at checkout to use
my code Ben got $25 off your first
in-home on-demand massage again zeal is
it's just fantastic it'll definitely
help you get in good with the inlaws and
the relatives if you are if you are
seeking to do that zeal ze Elcom and use
that promo code Ben okay so president
Trump is now pushing Roy Moore in the
robo call now I think this has to do
with more than just the Alabama Race and
I'll explain that in just a few minutes
here but first I think that it's clear
first let's play Trump's Robo call for
more so here's his Robo call for more
that's now playing Alabama Donald and I
need Alabama to go votes to Roy Moore it
is so important we're already making
America great again I'm going to make
America safer and stronger and better
than ever before but we need that seat
we need Roy voting for us
okay so Trump is of course making it
about the extra vote and it's true this
seat is important for Republicans but
there's something else that's going on
more than this okay and I'll tell you
what that is in just a second but first
one more see he's now changing his story
again now he says he never molested
anyone he had said always that he never
molested anyone but he had said that he
never knew any of the he'd said that he
knew some of the women then he said he
didn't know any of the women so now he's
saying you never molested anyone and he
didn't know any of the accusers so he
this if this had been his original story
it would've been a lot better one of the
things that lit him on fire was his
interview with sean hannity where he
said he generally didn't date women who
were underage and he always asked their
parents first that sort of said
a lot of folks well he's guilty of
something well now more is is changing
his story anything he's completely
innocent you have said that you did not
know them or had no encounter with them
that's my understanding I do not know
them I had no encounter with him I never
molested anyone and for them to say that
I don't know why they're saying it but
it's not true okay and that's gonna be
his line right his line is gonna be that
none of it's true he did not hit her he
did not I did not oh hi mark that's it
sorry you'll understand that reference
when we get to things I like a little
bit later in the show but but it's just
that this is his new line and he's going
to play it for all that it is worth now
why is Trump so focused on this the
reason that pump is focused on this is
because the entire media has blown this
up now not into just is this race and
endorsement of Trump that's what they
would have done normally if you were
just a normal Republican candidate they
would have turned this race into a
Democrat is challenging in Alabama that
means the Trump is unpopular and they
did that in Virginia when Anna Gillespie
lost his gubernatorial race over there
and when there was a big sweep in
Virginia they turned it into this was a
referendum on Trump there's something
else going on here everyone knows that
this is the first step in the move
against Trump himself on charges like
those used against Roy Moore on sexual
assault sexual harassment charges it's
the reason why Al Franken was thrown
under the bus last week the reason Al
Franken had to go under the bus the
reason that Al Franken had to be thrown
out of the Senate and he's still sitting
there by the way is because the entire
Democratic Party now wants to wheel it
hit Trump this is perfectly obvious even
Roy Morris strategy people are saying
this they're trying to drive the vote
out so they're saying that you have to
vote for more in order to vote for Trump
that's their line team yelling is the
chief political strategist for the more
campaign here's what he had to say you
say this is president Trump's agenda and
that's why it's so important that that
judge more win this race last night we
had Doug Jones the Liberal Democrat with
one of his Senate buddies Cory Booker
who said that that the president should
resign says Donald Trump on trial in
Alabama if the people of Alabama vote
for this Liberal Democrat
Doug Jones danced the president who they
put in office at the highest level so
it's very important for Donald Trump and
again it's ground zero for president
Donald Trump if they can beat him they
can beat his agenda because judge more
stands with Donald Trump and his agenda
and you can see this is the direction
he's right this is the direction
Democrats are moving Chuck Todd right
over on Emma on NBC and MSNBC he says
that after Al Franken resigns we have a
new standard now funny how the new
standard didn't apply when Bill Clinton
was in office funny how the new
standards didn't apply when Teddy
Kennedy was the Lion of the Senate funny
how the new standard didn't apply well
Hillary Clinton was running but boom
Hillary Clinton's done and now we're
back to a new standard it's an brand new
standard it's just amazing how that
works right the new standard is if you
sexually assault or sexually harass
people you should resign I'm old enough
to remember when that was the Republican
line but now this is the Democrat line
so here's Chuck Todd basically saying we
sacrificed Alfred can on the altar of
sexual goodness and now there must be
others who sacrifice themselves you can
see which direction this is going here's
Chuck Todd now within game I want to
talk Peggy about the Franken standard as
we now have a new standard for
resignation you could argue when it
comes out Frank and Ruth Marcus a
familiar face to many here of the
Washington Post wrote this there's no
doubt in the case of Al Franken the
Democrats are better off with the
Minnesota senator gone there's more
doubt about whether justice was done
I agree none of it is acceptable what
gives me pause is both the rush to
judgment and the one-size-fits-all
nature of the punishment fair enough but
we had you know this is a country trying
to establish it's certainly a US Senate
trying to establish Newt and ertz for
acceptable behavior and again funny how
the new standards only apply it's in his
Trump enters office here's Bernie
Sanders two weeks ago wouldn't get rid
of Al Franken now who should who should
leave it's Trump of course he was well I
don't know that you know what was in Al
Franken but the point is the point is
that we have the absurdity now of a
President of the United States who
basically says on a tape that everybody
in this country has seen his pride in a
sense in assaulting women and he has not
apologized for that and he has you know
not offered his resin
Oh what I just said is Al Franken felt
it proper for him to resign here you
have a president who is recused by many
women of assault who says on a tape that
he assaulted women he might want to
think about doing the same and you can
see that this is the direction that all
the Democrats are moving now now to be
fair to President Trump the p-word tape
is not it's not supremely clear on the
idea that Trump himself admitted to
grabbing women by the bleep right he
talks about how he moved very ahead of a
on one married woman he's talked to he
talked about how he likes to kiss women
he just can't stop himself from kissing
women but when he gets to the part where
he says you can grab them by the bleep
when you're famous they'll let you do
anything that's not actually an
admission of guilt that's him saying I
could do that right but it doesn't
really matter because in the end there
are a bunch of accusers that came out
and accused him of doing exactly that I
said this lad when this actually
happened last year I said as soon as
Trump says he's never done this there
will be a bevy of women who come forward
to say that he has done this and this
puts Republicans in a tough spot right
because all the Republicans who are
trying to say that Al Franken should
leave are now being cudgelled into the
what do we do about Trump corner you can
see this already starting to turn last
week I talked about this with Newt
Gingrich and Laura Ingraham both of whom
were saying maybe al franken should stay
that wasn't because they think Al
Franken should stay is because they
think Trump should stay right so this is
all broken down into perfectly powerless
partisan lines as soon as the Democrat
is is powerful enough that Democrats
have to keep him around then they will
drop the the standard and it'll be very
clear where their hypocrisy lies but
meanwhile Republicans are stuck in this
in this difficult position nikki Haley
who's the UN Ambassador to the Trump
administration she specifically says
that that all of these women who accused
President Trump should be heard and now
Republicans are boxed in a little bit
given that consciousness how do you
think people should assess the accusers
of the president well I mean you know
the same thing as women who accuse
anyone should be heard they should be
heard and they should be dealt with and
I think we heard from them prior to the
election and I think any woman who has
felt violated or felt mistreated in any
way they have every right to speak up
and does the election mean that's a
settled issue you
no that's for the people to decide I
know that he was elected but you know
women should always feel comfortable
coming forward and we should all be
willing to listen to them okay well that
obviously doesn't answer the question
and this is the the typical take that
you've heard about Roy Moore once you
apply any standard room or do you also
have to apply as Donald Trump that's
gonna be the question here's the reality
trumping going anywhere right Trump's
not gonna resign because Trump denies
all this stuff and also because even if
Trump did this stuff he's not somebody
who's really governed by by shame that's
not something that the President of the
United States has an ample supply is the
capacity for guilt or shame to his
benefit politically and to his detriment
morally in many cases but one of the
things that I think that in one of the
reasons the more thing has become a
microcosm is because everybody knows
what the next step is and the next step
was always coming and that was the
Democrats deciding to use the club of
Roy Moore and turn against Trump again
it's why they made the blood sacrifice
of Al Franken and John Conyers not
because they actually care about the
women now I'm going to talk about what
the media are doing to advance this
entire narrative in just a second but
first I want to say thanks to our
sponsors over at us CCA so we hear lots
of stories in the news about somebody
breaks into a house and a good guy uses
a gun to protect his family but then
he's the one arrested well thanks to our
court system this actually happens a
fair bit and that's exactly what could
happen to you if you're not fully
prepared
that's here's how you can take a simple
rewarding journey to complete firearms
and family defence confidence it's the
complete firearms and family defense
guide from our friends over the u.s. CCA
it's 100% free you will learn how to
detect attackers before they see you how
to survive a mass shooting the safest
most dangerous places to sit in a
restaurant how to responsibly own and
store a gun even if you have little kids
I have two little kids it is
particularly important to to responsibly
own and store agon a lot more it's 164
pages it comes with a complete audio
book you can listen in your car as well
as soon as the podcast is off all you
have to do is tune over and listen to
their complete firearms and family
defense guide from the US CCA
it is 100% free again for a limited time
you'll also get a bonus gun buying
checklist visit defend my family now to
calm defend my family now to the digit 2
dot-com right now for 100% free instant
access defend my family now to.com don't
forget the digit 2 at the end again
that's defend my family now to calm you
get free instant access to 164 page
guide that will teach you all you need
to know about detecting attackers and
surviving master
shootings and and how to responsibly own
and store gun and all the rest of these
vital piece of information our friends
over us CC are making gun ownership
safer and more worthwhile okay so the
media we get back to the media here
because the media are now forwarding
this narrative so you can see you know
Trump attacks the media because the
media attack him people respond to the
media's attacks by legitimated by
legitimizing Roy more Trump legitimizes
when more because of the media attacks
the media take the Roy Moore attack and
she's sweet and shifted to Trump which
in a certain perverse way actually
justifies Trump's distrust in the media
in the first place that's that's the
cycle of life here right the media
unfairly attacked Trump Trump attacks
the media people perceive the media as
being unfair the media report in my
opinion correctly on a bad Republican
Republicans rallied to that by
Republican sciences there and trust the
media the media then make a second move
by extending the ROI more stuff out to
President Trump in what I think is a
politically driven way and then the
Republicans disowned that and so the
spiral continues ever downward you can
see this today megyn kelly had three of
Donald Trump's accusers on The Today
Show today I'm Megan Kelly today she
brought on Samantha whole the Jessica
Leeds and Rachel crooks all of them say
that at some point they're on the
receiving end of behavior from Trump
ranging from forcible kissing to groping
these all these women showed up in the
middle of the campaign if you recall we
begin with a flashback to Jessica Leeds
here's Jessica Leeds one of the accusers
she suggested that Trump groped her
without permission there's back in 2016
I was sitting with him on an airplane
and he went after me on the plane yeah
I'm gonna go after believe me she would
not be my first choice that I can tell I
find it just ludicrous because he didn't
pick me I was there I was available and
he was bored that's that's all it was
that's all it was the other women who
are beautiful and and and beauty pageant
types and most of them have long blonde
hair which is something needs seems to
like he picked them but I was just
there okay so she is one of the accusers
I said that was one of the accusers
Kelly had on today second accusers woman
named Samantha holy she says that Trump
used to like walk through the Miss USA
pageant and then inspect the contestants
as I understand there you have an
experience of something that happened
the night before the pageant well not
the night before the pageant but when we
were in New York City on the media tour
they were doing a book launch at Trump
Towers for the universal Beauty book and
they had a bunch of former Miss USA s
and Miss universes and all 51 of us and
we did the red carpet that was tons of
fun and then they lined us all up and
Trump went down the line
and he shook your hand and you know
looked you over looked you up and down
head to toe it was just checking
everybody out and you thought you felt I
felt very dirty and it was very creepy
it's kind of like when you're at a bar
and a creepy guy is checking you out
that's that was the experience for me
okay so number one that is not actually
sexual assault okay and if it's sexual
harassment you are in the Miss USA
contest like where people gaze upon you
in your bathing suit like Donald Trump
runs it was it was anybody under the
impression that this was a class contest
like really but it's this is one of the
things that maybe are doing
they've lumped together everything from
Harvey Weinstein all the way down to
Samantha Hall they they did that in
order to get rid of Donald Trump one of
the reasons they started taking the
Weinstein stuff seriously is because
this is always going to wheel on
President Trump now should President
Trump have borne some responsibility for
the stuff that he did during the
campaign I think the answer is yes but
that should happen during the primaries
meaning once it got to the general
election then people had other concerns
there are a lot of people saying well
everybody ignore like one of these
accusers I think it was leads today was
saying that people ignored the
accusations about Trump nor to vote for
him I think a lot of people did do that
but I think it's unfair to suggest just
the same way it's unfair to suggest
everyone who's voting for more is doing
so in celebration of the allegations I
don't think it's fair to say that
everyone who voted for Trump was doing
so in celebration of these allegations
they're doing so they didn't want to
vote for Hillary Clinton a lot of the
people who vote for more are going to do
so because they don't want Roy Jones in
there or Doug
in there rather but the bottom line is
that the media always had an agenda here
now listen should President Trump step
down should President Trump step down
cuz of the sexual assault sexual
harassment allegations sure why not I
mean like honestly all these people
should okay I'm gonna say something
controversial now okay my controversial
thing is that everyone who was involved
in grabbing women by the bleep or
forcibly kissing women like Al Franken
or raping women like allegedly Bill
Clinton all these people should not be
in politics it was our job to be the
gatekeepers we didn't do it but if we
lived in an honorable politics would we
do it sure we would do it is it going to
happen now of course it's not going to
happen it's not going to happen so all
this really amounts to in the end is the
media bringing back up an old topic in
an attempt to shame Republicans for the
upcoming election that was always gonna
happen anyway by the way because the
bottom line is that Republicans we're
always going to have to embrace the
consequences of a man in high office who
is alleged to have done all of these
things and the allegations the list is
very long but that's not to suggest that
the media bias isn't very real the media
bias certainly Israel again I wish
everyone in politics were good and I
wish that voters held everyone to a
standard but obviously we don't okay so
as we continue on I want to talk a
little bit about what's going on in
Jerusalem so what's been amazing
actually is that the lack of terror
surrounding Trump's announcement that
Jerusalem was now going to be recognized
as the official capital of Israel it's
actually pretty amazing it's pretty
incredible that that so few so few acts
of terror have been committed in Israel
seems like everybody is sort of
distracted to tell the truth there have
been a few rallies here and there
there have been some some a little bit
of violence here and there but what's
really fascinating is the violence has
not been against Israelis the violence
has been against Jews and this is the
way that it works because all of the
people who pretend that anti-israel
sentiment anti-zionism is really just
about you just like what the State of
Israel is doing in the end it almost
universally ends up being you don't like
Jews very much and the way you can tell
this is for example what happened in
Malmo Sweden Tamamo in Sweden has become
a city that's largely been populated by
Muslims from the Middle East in
disproportionate fashion and a lot of
those people are anti-semites and so
here is a rally in Malmo where hundreds
of people were literally
chanting kill the Jews arm me make me of
service is down with the House of Saud
strike them with knives strike strike do
not be afraid then we die Palestine
lives these charmers are in the West by
the way these tremors are in the middle
of Sweden and they started chanting in
the middle of this thing about how JEWS
should be killed right we want to we
want to go shoot Jews so just really
nice
there was a Molotov cocktail but was
thrown into Swedish synagogue over the
weekend because obviously every
synagogue is Israel because everybody
identifies Jews with Israel and more
importantly they identify Israel with
Jews which is the reason they hate
Israel in the first part in the first
place according to New York Daily News
three people were arrested after a
synagogue in Sweden was attacked with
Molotov cocktails on Saturday night
about two dozen people for attending a
youth party inside the synagogue in
Gothenburg when suspects through burning
bottles against the building police told
goat Borges pasta and the kids inside
took refuge in the basement according to
a mother who spoke to express and her
daughter was in the building and texted
her during the incident mom I'm getting
scared she wrote authorities arrived at
the scene around 10 p.m. put out a fire
in the parking lot the building didn't
catch on fire no one was injured
but again another another attack on a
synagogue having nothing to do with
Israel but you know Jews are the targets
in the middle of Times Square and to
submit a chance calls for a new
synagogue in Times Square in the middle
of New York over all of this and yet all
these folks in it this has nothing to do
with anti-semitism like nothing at all
[Applause]
[Music]
happening right in the middle of Times
Square but don't worry folks it has
nothing to do with anti-semitism clearly
the only reason that the Muslim world is
upset is because of Trump and Jerusalem
they weren't upset before that you know
everything was hunky-dory before that
you know all the Palestinian knife
attacks in the middle of Jerusalem and
ramming vehicles into into toddlers and
strollers in the middle of the Jerusalem
train station and the shootings of
people in the middle of the street in
Jerusalem like all that was happening
before Trump said any of this but really
it was all Trump's fault you see what
happened is that Trump all the other
Palestinians and their allies they they
went back in time and they knew already
that Trump was gonna say this and so
they went back like to 1929 it started
slaughtering Jews in Hebron because they
felt like Trump was eventually gonna say
something about your Islam that's
clearly what's going on here it does
give the why to the ridiculous
stupid asinine idea that the movement
against Jews in Israel is not a movement
against Jews it's just a movement
against Israel and the real reason
they're upset is because of Trump
they're not upset about Trump Trump
honestly they're less upset about Trump
than I've seen them about anything in a
while because they're they're distracted
with Iran at least a lot of the these
Sunni Muslims who normally would be up
in arms about this sort of thing this is
the right move by President Trump it was
a good move by President Trump and again
anti-semitism is going to exist across
the world and target Israel because
there are a lot of Jews there people
hate Israel BK's because they hate the
Jews they don't hate the Jews because
they hate Israel they've hated the Jews
for thousands of years before the modern
State of Israel it's just one of the
Dumber arguments I've heard in the
recent past is that if Israel were just
kinder if Israel had divided Jerusalem
than all of this would have gone away
Jerusalem was divided from 1948 to 1967
that did not stop terror it did not stop
the the Arab armies from attempting war
in 1956 as well as 1967 and so all of
this is sheer nonsense of the highest
order okay
in other crazy news it turns out that
the Senate Republicans are bad at pretty
much everything according to richard
rubin
some high-income business owners could
face marginal tax rates exceeding 100
percent
under the Senate tax bill really a
hundred percent under the Senate tax
bill far beyond the listed rates in the
Republican plan that means a business
owners next to one hundred percent in
earnings under certain circumstances
would require paying more than a hundred
dollars in additional federal and state
taxes as lawmakers rushed to write the
final tax bill over the next week
they're already looking at changes to
prevent this from happening so they just
they rush this thing through and it
actually includes the idea that if you
were a married self-employed New Jersey
lawyer with three kids and earnings of
about six hundred fifteen grand then you
would actually pay a hundred and five
dollars in taxes for every one hundred
dollars more in business income so well
done drawing this bill does you use it a
spectacular job as typical Republicans
just doing yeoman's work on behalf of
their own ideas okay well we're going to
talk a little bit about things I like
and things I hate in federalist papers
but before that we're gonna have to
break from Facebook and YouTube for that
you're gonna have to subscribe at daily
where $9.99 a month gets you a
subscription today Lee Weyer calm and
with that subscription comes the rest of
my show live on video comes Andrew
Clavin show live on video comes Michael
Knowles's show live on video all of
those shows come to you live on video
which is awesome plus you also get to be
part of our mailbag so tomorrow right
tomorrow is the conversation at 5 p.m.
Eastern 2 p.m. Pacific you will be join
the conversation if you subscribe you
can ask a question to me directly and I
will go through your questions one by
one I will either answer them or mock
them you just don't know that's where
the surprise comes in you get to be part
of the conversation when you become a
subscriber we're gonna broadcast it live
on YouTube we're gonna broadcast it live
on Facebook
and you will get to watch it for free
but only subscribers can ask questions
and have all of their life's problems
answered by me so daily wire.com head
over to the conversation page to watch
the live stream and just start typing
into the daily wear chat box and i'll
answer questions as they come in for an
entire hour that's a good reason to
subscribe check that out if you want the
annual subscription then go over to
daily wire comm pick it up for 99 bucks
a year when you do you also get this the
very finest in all beverage vessels the
leftist year's hot or cold tumbler you
can enjoy it at every meal so make sure
that you go over there and do that and
subscribe also if you just want to
listen later YouTube iTunes SoundCloud
subscribe leave us a review we always
appreciate it we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
all righty so I'm gonna leave some time
for some things I like in things I hate
and the Federalist paper of the day
every Monday we go through a federalist
paper we are now up to Federalist number
7s who will get to that okay so we begin
with things I like so I will admit I
have not seen this entire movie yet
Mathis by my producer has been highly
recommending the room for for at least a
week to me ever since I learned of this
movie that has asked artists James
Franco is like what is that about he
said well there's this movie the room
and it is a so bad it's good classic
it's just an amazing film Mathis owns a
copy of it that he forgot at home you
cannot stream this apparently you have
to get it on DVD but but you got but you
that's right Mathis says you have to
commit and the and yet but you can watch
the best scenes of it on YouTube and I
will say this you know Mathis says you
have to watch the whole thing to get the
humour of the room you don't actually
have to watch the whole thing you just
have to watch some of the scenes because
they are incredible so I for you have
brought together a couple of the scenes
from the room it's a masterpiece of bad
cinema basically the story here's a guy
named Tommy was so is the producer
writer and director of this piece of hot
garbage
he's an Eastern European guy who no one
knows where he came from he won't say
how old he is somehow he came up with
six million dollars so I assumed that he
robbed a bank somewhere and he came to
the United States and decided to make
what easily is the worst movie of all
time it's true but he meant it to be
good he didn't mean it to be parodic I
mean he meant it to actually be a good
movie he stars in it he's supposed to be
an all-american guy he sounds like a
Transylvanian vampire apparently there
was originally a scene where he would
turn into a vampire in the film that was
cut unfortunately that would've made it
even greater it might have killed it
because it might have it might have
actually broken the realism of the of
the terribleness but here here are a few
scenes from the room again this is in
the news because James Franco made a
movie called the disaster artist about
the making of this terrible terrible
film this is America man you can make a
garbage film get rich off of it and then
so and then a big star will make a film
about your garbage film and the making
of it incredible here's some actual
scenes from the room you'll see the
charm of it in just a few seconds
yeah can I have a dozen red roses please
oh hi Johnny I didn't know what you here
you go that's me
how much is it it'll be $18 go keep the
change
hi doggie you're my favorite customer
thanks a lot bye did not hit her it's
not true it's both did not hit her I did
not oh hi mark
people are very strange these days he's
know a girl she had a dozen guys one of
them found out about it beat her up so
bad she ended up in a hospital in
Guerrero Street what a story mark okay
it's amazing it's amazing and what more
is there to say about if you want to see
something really funny watch that watch
the compa lady the compiled scenes a
compilation and then go over to go over
to the honest trailers version of the
room because it's very very funny but
this thing has become now a cult classic
and for a good reason I did not that
that was my reference earlier - I did
not hit her I did not its oh hi mark
amazing amazing I have to say my single
favorite thing there is is the story
about the woman who's beaten so badly
she ends up in a hospital and Tommy
Wiseau laughs ha ha ha what a story mark
that's that that was his take away
incredible ok so from the ridiculous to
the sublime over the weekend I had the
opportunity to read in a biography about
Beethoven by a guy named John Suchet he
is the BBC commentator on Beethoven the
it's not a kind of the most in-depth
biography of Beethoven gives you the
broad strokes of his life there's a
little bit too much speculation for my
taste but the biography is very readable
and it's a very quick read so if you
want sort of the background on who
Beethoven was and all of his trouble
the biggest problem that I have with
people's kind of takes on Beethoven is
they put a lot of focus on his love life
and the immortal beloved letter and all
this kind of stuff I think that has very
little do with his art Beethoven's art
was all about his his level of skill his
mastery of music the really seismic
developments in music that he was
responsible for over the rest of the
week I'm gonna pick some Beethoven
pieces that show you sort of the the
mastery that Beethoven had over his art
and we'll talk a little bit about what's
unique about
in this week because I was you know this
weekend I was thinking I haven't been
enjoying things as much as I as much as
I ought lately and I think that's
because I wasn't listening to enough
music really I was I was listening to
too much talk I was listening to I was
instead of spending time just listening
to uplifting music I was spending time
on other things and that was a mistake
and so I had some chances to listen to
some great music over the weekend and it
really lifted my spirits which i think
is important so this is a good place to
start you can pick up the book Beethoven
the man revealed by John Suchet worth
reading okay time for a couple of things
that I hate alright so we begin with
this video that's now gone viral of a
student I guess he's in Tennessee who
was bullied at school and he was talking
on videos mom took a tape of him live I
roll all these celebrities pledged their
support I want to talk a little bit
about what's happening here okay what do
they say to you what they do tell you at
lunch put milk on me hand up my clothes
nothing is it just you yep where is it
other kids too bit bill that way so
they're good shoe how does that make you
feel okay so they're a couple things
about this so number one as someone who
is viciously bullied in school I can say
that this is what this kids experiencing
is is not just real it's like if you've
actually been through this experience
you know what this feels like you've
been exactly where this kid is I have to
say I don't like that the mom took this
tape and put it online I don't like that
I think that this is a situation where
the mom needs to March herself in the
principal's office and take care of
business or she needs to walk over to
the kids houses and take care of
business this is something I intend on
doing with my own kid if this ever
becomes an issue if my kid bullies you
know I'm not big on spanking like it's
not a thing in my house but if my kid
became a bully that would be a time for
spanking I really would but you know my
father was was the person who went in
and took care of biz
when it came to bullying I think I've
told the stories on the show before I
don't like embarrassing this kid this
kid forever is now going to be
associated with being the kid who's
crying over being bullied and yes that
brings you some national sympathy and
yes a lot of celebrities will come out
of the woodwork to talk about terrible
bullying is because it is it is just
awful
but I think that the only way that we're
actually gonna solve this problem is not
on a national level with celebrities
saying things it's gonna be on a
parental level with parents going out
and doing something about it so I wish
that mom had had instead of taking this
tape I wish that mom and marched herself
over the principal's office
and threatened some consequences or went
over to the parents houses and
threatened some consequences and made
sure this did not happen again I wish
that she had gotten this kid fighting
lesson so the kid could kick the crap
out of his boys I think that's a better
short-term solution than an long-term
solution actually then putting tapes
like this up online just feel awful for
this kid I feel awful for him and and
everybody celebrating this how great
it's gonna be you know what's gonna
happen to this kid six months after
after all the celebrities are gone
six months after all the celebrities are
gone all the celebrities have gone back
to making their movies and they've gone
back to being the beautiful people this
kid is gonna get it twice as hard from
the rest of the bullies in his class
that's how this works it's it's just
yeah okay
other things that I hate so there was a
fellow named Daniel shaver well he's a
white guy who was a who was apparently
pointing a BB gun out of his window and
a bunch of hotel guests saw it and they
and they called the cops the cops show
up and they shoot him to death here's a
little bit of the tape
[Applause]
towards me okay so they they murdered
they killed this guy I mean it looks it
looks a lot like murder right you can
see that his hand moves sort of toward
his waistband and this is the excuse
that they're using as they reach behind
him but this is this video is like seven
minutes long they brought him out in the
hallway they shouted all sorts of
contradictory commands they told him to
put his hands behind his head and then
crawl toward them and then the minute
that he like puts it a she told me put
his hands kind of I guess behind his
head and crawl toward them like you
can't actually do all these things so
you have one idiot supervisor who is
yelling all these commands this guy the
guy's name was dead with shavers Daniel
shaver he was 26 years old he'd been
doing rubbish shots at the woman he'd
met earlier in the day showing off a
pellet gun he used in his job and pest
control the graphic video was recorded
by brailles for his body camera and it
showed shaver and the woman exiting the
hotel room immediately complying with
commands from multiple officers he puts
his hands in the air he lies down on the
ground while informing the officer and
no one else was in the hotel room and
one of the officers got him charles
language says if you make a mistake
another mistake there's a very severe
possibility you're both gonna get shot
he said I'm not her to be taxable in
diplomatic with you you listen you obey
and then he gives him he gives him
orders for five solid minutes five solid
minutes he's playing he's playing you
know put your right foot in put your
right foot out he's playing the
hokey-pokey with him he's playing Simon
Says
he tells an aunt he tells she him to put
both his hands on top of his head then
he instructions across his left foot
over his right foot the guy's completely
drunk and then he says if you move we're
gonna consider that a threat and then he
says crawl down the hallway and he tells
him to keep his legs crossed push
himself up into a kneeling position and
then his legs
come on cross prompting the officer to
scream at him and then he puts his hand
near his waist prompting another round
of screaming and he said you do that
again I'm gonna shoot you and this is
please don't shoot me and then he crawls
down the hallway and at one point
because he's been lying face down his
shorts are falling down and he's drunk
he moves to pull up his shorts and then
they shoot him to death and the rifle
that he was carrying this cop was etched
with the phrase you're effed
just fantastic guys just fantastic now
a couple things worth pointing out here
one bad training matters number two
juries almost always give the benefit of
the doubt to the cop so a lot of the
evidence that was presented talked about
the sort of threat that had been
reported by people in the next-door room
they were afraid that if they walked
over to the guy there might be someone
behind the door who was gonna pop out
and shoot them so the officer was
acquitted in this case but number three
the level of national outrage over this
case is not even there been no riots
that have been no protest nothing and
the reason for that is because the guy
who was shot is white it's been
perfectly frank about this it's because
we are more concerned with Rachel
conflagrations in this nation than we
are really about police brutality this
is a pretty clear-cut case of police
brutality and police miss action and the
level of outrage over it is not even
close to the level of outrage over
Michael Brown who is justifiably shot by
witness testimony and by the end by
circumstantial evidence so it's just
just a horrifying video right there and
it goes to show you that you know cops
and bad situations sometimes make bad
choices this looks like manslaughter to
me it's very least okay gonna go through
Federalist seven really fast so every
week we go through a federalist paper we
are making our way all the way through
the Federalist Papers Federalist number
seven this is Alexander Hamilton again
and here he discusses possible sources
of discord between the states if we
weren't to form a national government
and we were just to have a bunch of
states with their own governments and
why would that bring us to conflict and
it's actually very pressured because he
talks about all of these reasons why
states could get into a war and all of
them are reasons that the states
eventually get into the Civil War
despite the presence of the US
Constitution so it begins by talking
about territorial disputes he says
territorial disputes have at all times
been found one of the most fertile
sources of hostility among nations
perhaps the greatest proportion of wars
that have desolated the earth have
sprung from this origin this cause would
exist among us in full force we have a
vast tract of unsettled territory within
the boundaries of the United States
they're still discordant and undecided
claims between several of them and the
dissolution of the Union would lay a
foundation for similar claims between
them all in the wide field of western
territory therefore we perceive an ample
theater for hostile pretensions without
any umpire or common judge to interpose
between the contending parties in other
words there's a whole western area of
the United States none of it's settled
the state of South Carolina wants to
claim that the state of the new york
wants to claim it they get into a war
over it this is actually what happened
right this is what it was called
bleeding Kansas and there was a
referendum there was a piece of
legislation
that said that when the state of Kansas
was admitted to the Union when Kansas
Territory was admitted to the Union the
people of Kansas would be able to vote
on whether it was a slave state or a
free state and he had slave owners
rushing to the state and then he had
freeholders rushing to the state and
going to war literally with each other
and there were massacres of Americans by
Americans this is basically a small
civil war in Kansas called bleeding
Kansas so Hamilton was not wrong about
this even in the presence of a federal
government then he says there would be
trade disputes between these various
states he says each state or separate
Confederacy would pursue a system of
commercial policy peculiar to itself
this was actually not healed by the
federal government either there was very
nearly a civil war in the 1830s over the
so called tariff of abominations that
was when the the North decided to put
tariffs on goods coming in that were to
be used by the south and the South was
very upset about this and threatened
nullification right this is a
nullification crisis that Andrew Jackson
swore to to basically break the south
over so we very nearly came to blows
over trade this is public debt he's
talking about the public debt accrued by
the war it'd be very difficult to
apportion that without a national
government to actually collect and
finally laws in violation of private
contracts the idea being you sign a
contract with somebody from another
state and that other state then just
nullifies the contract this could cause
severe conflict this in fact did cause
severe conflict because the Fugitive
Slave Act was designed to was designed
to enforce property holdings in people
and human beings that were evil in the
south that was what the Fugitive Slave
Act was designed to do it helped
exacerbate division so the point that
I'm making here is that Hamilton was
right about the fact that if you don't
have a strong federal government or at
least a federal government strong enough
that we all have national legions to it
you end up getting in wars with each
other the federal government was not
sufficient to prevent those Wars from
breaking out over exactly the reasons
Hamilton saw them breaking out okay
so we'll be back here tomorrow with all
the latest fallout in politics and pop
culture I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex zingaro audio is mixed by
Mike or Mina hair and makeup is by Jo
opera the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright Ford publishing 2017